[Music]
hi everyone
i'm justin k thompson and i am the
production designer for spider-man
into the spider-verse when we were
working on the animated film the most
exciting part of the process was
bringing miles morales to life
on the big screen for the first time in
a way that had never been
seen before we knew how special the
character was and that we wanted to give
him
his own unique style of animation and
it's been amazing to see the way
audiences have responded to the movie
and now it's exciting to see that
insomniac games and playstation
in collaboration with marvel games
created its own take on the character
in marvel's spider-man miles morales
coming out for ps5 and ps4 the way
insomniac
faithfully brought the iconic suit
designed for spider-man
into the spider-verse into the game is
visually stunning and remarkable
we were able to advise on some of the
unique design elements that made the
film
so distinct like how we often animated
the characters on
twos and we made recommendations for how
best to integrate the pop-up words and
the little burst cards on screen
into the action sequences
hey the underground's messing with a
billboard just pinged it
the underground must be nearby if
they're hijacking that billboard
gotta lock onto the signal so i can find
where the underground's hiding
locking on all right
now to track them underground's trying
to get the press to notice them more
maybe they should launch an apt
the underground as advertised
do you think anyone's building that
underground brand going
on
ah
transmitter around here
[Music]
brilliant neighborhood spider-man 1
underground advertising campaign
zero
[Music]
christmas
[Music]
something's weakening emergency
responder communications
should check it out
spider-man thank god something's
weakening our emergency comps
we can't get through the fire department
is anyone still inside
no we got everyone out but this fire's
gonna jump if we don't get help
hear that just noise now i think i can
find the source
don't worry i'm gonna get your comms
back up
the sooner i get to the source the
sooner the fire trusts get here
my webs can't handle a fire this big
[Music]
whatever's weakening the signal is just
ahead
fire's burning real good and all i'm
hearing is static guess powering down
the tower worked
insurance only pays out if the whole
building goes down so make sure the
static stays till then
they're weakening calms for an insurance
scam i've got to stop them
hey you sure you know what you're doing
there yeah i watched one of those video
tutorials
seriously there's one for everything on
the internet
in a week payday is
sorry guys you really should have gone
for the spider-man insurance
[Music]
a week because there's no power i need
to charge up that generator
hey mr emt dudes are trying to burn down
that building for an insurance scam
that's why they're messing with your
comms are you serious
they're putting people in danger yeah
how's the fire looking
i'm getting real close to jumping to the
building next door and i still can't
reach the fire department
signal should be clear soon hang tight
i'll update you
getting close
hang on the signal's stronger now
ah what'd you do why are you always
assuming things are my fault
huh what's that about can't wait i gotta
get those calms back to normal
kinda feel a little bad for the
neighbors what if the fire spreads
you must be new here hey just fight a
man
whoever takes him out for your bonus
think that's freaking fanny
stay out of my business freak show
wow
now to get the comms back to full power
there i think that worked i should check
on the fire
and make sure comms are back up hey
how's the signal
now everything's coming through loud and
clear got through to dispatch too
fire trucks are pulling up now
hmm
[Music]
okay
fire department got the building
extinguished just in time i'm definitely
giving europe five stars
glad i could help spread the word too
the more people use the app the safer
will make new york
i'm gonna make sure everybody knows
about it thanks again spider-man
[Music]
mom was right neighborhood's gorgeous
oh
i myself am a huge fan of comic books so
i'm excited that fans like me will get
the opportunity to play a game with
miles morales
in the lead role thank you to insomniac
our friends at playstation and marvel
games
for inviting me to be a part of this
video we can't wait to see it all come
together